[inaudible]
Qatar is the wealthiest country on the
planet.
They're citizens enjoy a higher GDP per
capita than the Swiss,
or indeed any of the nationals from any
of the other oil rich monarchies.
But today we are not going to talk about
this.
In fact,
the most important factor of this
country is not their wealth,
nor their absolute monarchy or their
ties with radical terrorist green.
Any doubt what made this country famous
can be summarized in just two words,
and those words are Algebra zero.
It is the most influential TV network in
the Arab world as one of the most
important news networks on the entire
planet.
But at the beginning of the 1990s the
royal family that rules guitar with an
Iron Fist,
the Al Tawny House had a dream.
They wanted to turn the nation into the
hedge and monique leader in the region.
But the question was,
how could they achieve this goal?
I mean,
we're talking about a tiny country with
a smaller population than the city of
Chicago.
Of course they couldn't rival Saudi
Arabia in the military fields and sharia
law made it impossible to be a financial
powerhouse.
Further,
their geographical position was nothing
special either.
There was only one possible strategy and
that was the idea of so called soft
Hawaii
and otherwise influenced diplomacy.
Well proper Ganzer.
Since then,
Qatar has invested more than any other
country in improving their image to
outsiders by doing things like hosting
the soccer World Cup in 2020 to a
formula one race and even directly
sponsoring soccer teams.
Among all these projects,
the most successful am's famous of them
all has to be their TV network,
Algebra Xera.
They aren't the market leader in terms
of audience in the entire Arab wells.
In fact,
their market share some policies all of
their rivals put together,
and this is all despite the fact that
the channel is banned in most countries.
I'll just say rabbi has led to the
overthrow of governments in several
nations.
They have amplified the effects of the
Arab spring and they've even become the
unofficial loudspeaker for some
terrorist groups since the attacks of
September the 11th Algers era has become
in many ways the only source of
information for understanding what is
going on in some parts of the worlds.
Even CNN buys their footage.
In other words,
they are a respected media institution,
but then again you might wonder,
well,
isn't Al Jazeera just a state propaganda
channel?
I mean,
to what extent should we really trust
their information and it's importantly
what's their,
well,
today we are going to answer all of
these questions,
but before we do that,
let's take a look at some history.
Importance of being unique.
In 1995 the BBC clothes,
that Arab channel,
because the Saudi government wanted to
interfere in their editorial process,
150 journalism's got fired.
All of them are of journalists who were
trained at one of the most prestigious
media organizations in the world.
These people have a deep knowledge of
Muslim culture,
but at the same time they couldn't meet
the high standards of Western media.
This is where the emir of Qatar at the
time,
the hammered I'll tawny comes in.
Right,
okay.
Tommy had just come to power,
had a clear vision for his country.
He wanted it to become the leader of the
Islamic world.
In order to achieve that,
those 150 unemployed journalists weren't
given an opportunity.
As soon as they lost their jobs.
Qatar offered them brands,
new ones.
Now what was their mission?
Well,
that was to create a brand new news
network and Arab speaking media route
and led that would meet the quality of
Western media bounce.
Benny cost has governments gave them a
$147 million loan and with that,
this team of 150 journalists could by
state of the art studios.
I've correspondence in many countries
and broadcast through a satellite.
Everything
little detail was taken care of,
for example,
to design their logo via media made a
public contest.
Finally,
this one,
the one that you see on the screen now
was the winner and as you can see and
reads Algers Aaron
[inaudible] in 1996 Al Jazeera.
That means the island in Arabic started
broadcasting to the Arab world in very
little time at all.
They surpass the rest of their rivals.
I think about it.
I need,
back in the day,
Arab TV was extremely boring in this
part of the world.
Freedom of expression doesn't really
exist and is therefore tv news just
offered official announcements.
I'll zero.
It was different.
They had a new problem with criticizing
various politicians and royal families.
They showed corruption scandals,
Sam's,
they even interviewed political
dissonance.
All of this was done in a dynamic style
that had never been seen on Arabic
television before.
Nevertheless,
the real turning point for elders here,
right,
was nine 11 or some have been laws and
use this TV networks or broadcast his
claim to the terrorist attack.
All of a sudden,
the name Algebra Syrup was being said on
TV.
News arounds the wells butts and
autonomy that a month after the
terrorist attack,
the American government declared war on
Afghanistan.
Back then,
all the big media corporations like CNN
or CNBC had correspondence in Tokyo,
London,
or Berlin.
There's no one had thought Kabul would
be that newsletter.
Great.
Don's well.
Dessie did an office in the Afghan
capital.
Yup.
That would be Algebra Jazeera.
Since they were a channel targeted to
the Muslim world,
they had correspondence in all of the
Muslim countries.
Suddenly Algers era footage was
appearing on televisions all around the
world.
This is why in 2004 the emir of Qatar
realized that what he had it not only
was a powerful tool to reach the Arab
world,
but indeed the world at large and this
is how English elder Xero was born and
it was ready to broadcast into the most
competitive media market in the world
for United States of America.
Thanks.
Then Al Jazeera has become the TV news.
The book's about countries that never
appear on American TV news wants to know
about Africa.
Well tuned down with was era.
What about the Middle East?
Again,
go to Al Jazeera Central Asia.
Yup.
You're beginning to get the picture.
Lots of do.
Wait a minute because things are not
quite as great as they seem to be.
Don't forget to,
we are talking about a TV now.
It's work that is being paid for by
government in order to influence other
countries.
Starting to sounds a bit like it might
be propaganda.
Well,
let's dive a little bit deeper.
Islam's on fault.
[inaudible] as we said before,
Algebra's era was the first Arab TV
network that openly criticized the
governments in other countries.
We started the revolution back in 2011
rather.
Yeah.
I'm surprisingly,
this was not always welcome,
especially given that most of these
other countries are dictatorships.
So in 2011 an uprising in Tunisia
started out and the dictator of this
nation abandoned.
There's all of these facts.
Could have had little to no impact
abroad.
There's Al Jazeera handed deep coverage
of this uprising so that it can be seen
in other countries.
Since it was a satellite station,
this signal was arriving,
decides all across north Africa and the
Arabian peninsula.
See,
that
is how the inhabitants in other
countries and next to Tina,
Ziad like Egypt saw their neighbor's
protesting and thought,
wait a minute,
we've also got a dictator.
Couldn't we do something just like that
ends.
Of course,
nearly every person in oppositions,
you've never like had a news show that
they could now watch ads.
Of course,
this was not something that wins over
and brilliantly.
Windows dictator.
Yeah,
I'll just,
or a shutdown in Egypt as Mubarak fights
for control of Airway,
right.
Well,
what exactly is the problem here?
censoring the satellite TV station is
harder than it seems.
Of course.
You can forbid it if you want,
but if someone wants to access the
station and they have a satellite dish,
then technically it's possible.
If you were having problems receiving
any allergies,
there are channels.
This guide will take you through the
process of tuning your satellite
receiver,
sorry.
In a matter of a month,
all of these Arab citizens were seeing
then neighboring countries overthrowing
their dictators and this explains in
part the Arab spring phenomenon.
No,
wait a minute again because not
everything is perfect.
Of course.
Salvagers there it helps to finish off a
lot of dictatorships,
but the truth is the people they
promoted on their network when not
really any more democratic.
We came down for years.
The Muslim Brotherhood spiritual leader
was given his own television show on Al
Jazeera,
even dash the Islamic state was
portrayed by Al Jazeera as Johnston
opposition force to al Assad in Syria
and even as a group of moderate rebels.
The same happens with other Sunni
radical terrorists like al Qaeda and now
you might be wondering is Al Jazeera and
network as it stands for radicalism and
against the West?
Well,
the truth is they've also been accused
of just the opposite.
Just ask the mayor of Bahrain and as
governor,
Yeah,
Information Nabeel,
I'll hummer told journalists that Al
Jazeera correspondence had been banned
from Bahrain.
I'll hummer claimed that the station was
a medium for quote Zionist infiltration
of the Gulf
free drinks.
Surprised well for many Alphas era is a
Zionist western propaganda.
While for others it's the TV station of
the radicals in fact is the only common
grounds for Al Jazeera when it comes to
ideology is the interests of the ones
who finance them.
The royal house of Owl Tawny,
who by the way don't support freedom of
speech and that beaks cables claim algae
zero changed coverage to suit Qatari
foreign policy.
Nevertheless,
if this doesn't mean they cannot show
the dark side of guitar in fact to
display being paid for by the royal
house.
Eldora Xera is more independent than
many other states sponsored news net
blacks
for instance.
What you see on the screen here are
extracts from a talk show about being
near slave,
like whacking conditions suffered by
immigrants,
see work in Qatar as construction
workers.
This show foreign trade unionists were
invited and had the chance to open the
criticize the Al Tiny family and their
policies.
In other words,
Algebra,
there is directors are smart enough to
limit that propaganda and not lose their
audience.
Of course they have an ideology and a
lot of interests to meet but they are
all aware but in today's world you
cannot silence the reality of what's
happening because if you don't tell us,
oh this is going to tell it for you.
The end of the day.
Al Jazeera is forbidden in almost all
countries in the region,
including Saudi Arabia.
Nonetheless,
they are still the most influential
amels,
most watched TV network.
Everyone knows who pays for them,
but at the same time that they are the
only source for many of the topics.
In fact,
the Al Jazeera model has lots of
copycats.
In 2003 the Saudis founded their own
channel ally Realia.
Further of the American government has
their own narrative speaking network
called Aha Ron.
What about Iranian TV?
His farm TV as a Spanish speaking
network paid for by the Iranian
government in order to influence the
Hispanic world.
They also have an English speaking
channel called press TV and 2005 Russia
launched Russia today also known as
[inaudible].
Wow.
Algebra here,
rob keeps exploring new possibilities.
Their latest creation is a plus j a
facebook page where they share viral.
Yes.
As now all question,
it goes to you and that would be,
do you think you'd stop watching Al
Jazeera because you think it's
propaganda or when do you keep enjoying
the show as well?
Maybe adding a pinch of salt.
You can leave me your answer in the
comment section below.
I'd love to Harris and also talking
about propaganda.
We've got another video where we talk
about why Putin is a popular among
Russians.
If you want to watch that,
please do click on that link and also do
not forget to visit our friends from
reconsider media.com who provided the
voice in this video of it isn't mine.
Also,
if you liked this video,
please do give it a thumbs up and don't
forget that we publish brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so just hit that subscribe button.
Do not miss any post,
and as always I'll see you in the next
video and if you want to learn more
about politics and hear even more of my
lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast.